il est environ 10 13 milliards d'années
un phénomène spatiale inattendu connu
sous le nom de big bang a créé tout un
ensemble de galaxies parmi ces galaxie
la voie lactée est caractérisée par un
système solaire particulier en ce sens
qu'une planète sur une planète de ce
système il y a environ 4 milliards
d'années de l'eau est apparu cette
planète vous l'avez tous reconnu s'agit
de la terre il est environ 3,8 milliards
d'années
il s'est passé quelque chose de tout à
fait extraordinaire un ensemble de
molécules se sont assemblés au hasard
pour former le premier matériel
génétique
ce matériel génétique a ensuite évolué
pour donner la première cellule vivante
sur terre cette cellule au fur et à
mesure des millénaires s'est multiplié
elle s'est diversifiée
elle s'est spécialisée pour donner
environ 8,7 millions d'espèces sur terre
qui ont peuplé où qui peuplent encore
notre planète que ce soit cet oiseau ce
poisson ces algues monocellulaires ou 7
jong une des espèces qui nous intéresse
particulièrement
aujourd'hui c'est la nôtre c'est homo
sapiens sapiens à savoir l'être humain
c'est une espèce particulière qui se
différencie de la plupart des autres
avec le dauphin parce que c'est une
espèce qui a développé un système
nerveux central complexe et qui a
développé la capacité d'utiliser plus de
10% de son cerveau notamment pour
observer étudier son environnement
l'être humain a tenté également de
s'approprier cet environnement pour
améliorer sa condition créer des cités
modernes
une des façons un des chemins pour
étudier son environnement c'est lequel
c'est un chemin qui ont concerne
beaucoup ici il s'agit de l'université
alors l'université à l'heure actuelle en
europe
elle a la particularité d'être structuré
en faculté au sein de chaque faculté
l'université a comme rôle de former des
professionnels de formes et différentes
personnes qui vont avoir un certain
métier plus tard
certaines de ces personnes vont décider
de faire de la recherche scientifique
dans un domaine particulier voire deux
domaines particuliers à l'heure actuelle
le concept de la recherche scientifique
et de l'université en europe
c'est un concept où il y a généralement
dans chaque faculté un noyau dur de
chercheurs voire de chercheurs ou même
de professeurs qui proviennent de cette
même faculté
autrement dit quand vous regardez en
faculté d'ingénierie plupart des
chercheurs sont ingénieurs quand vous
regardez en psycho la plupart des
chercheurs sont psychologues et durant
toute leur vie ils se concentrent sur un
ou deux voire trois domaines de
recherche précis qui correspondent à des
domaines où ils sont censés devenir
l'expert
ça c'est le concept actuel de
l'université et de la recherche en
europe alors oui parfois c'est vrai il y
a des liens et des relations qui se font
entre différentes facultés
est ce que vous pensez pas qu'il est
temps de remettre en question ce mode de
fonctionnement
quand vous regardez en faculté
d'ingénierie ce qui se passe c'est que
les étudiants qui font polytech et bien
au terme de leur cursus
on a maturé leur cerveau d'une certaine
façon ils adoptent un mode de
fonctionnement propre à ce qu'on leur a
transmis dans cette faculté qui n'est
peut-être pas le même mode de
fonctionnement que les psychologues ou
que les médecins n'est-il pas temps
justement de remettre en question ce
concept pour tendre
faire plus de multidisciplinarité je
vais vous illustrez ça pourquoi est ce
que dans les domaines où c'est
compatible
on ne mélange ray pas les différents
chercheurs pour émettre des physiciens
davantage de physiciens à polytech des
psychologues en médecine obtient entre
nous je pense que ça ferait pas de tort
à beaucoup de médecins
on pourrait mettre également des
ingénieurs en faculté de médecine et de
mettre ça en faculté d'ingénieurs bref
on pourrait mettre l'un à côté de
l'autre
des chercheurs qui ont un mode de
fonctionnement et un mode de pensée
entendez là une maturation cérébrale
différentes pour ensemble développer de
projets de recherche
alors ces projets de recherche il
n'aurait peut-être pas à cette
configuration là mais il aurait une
configuration qui ressemble plutôt à
celle ci avec plus de transversalité et
d'interconnexion c'est ça qui est
important
ça c'est donc le premier concept alors
vous allez me dire ouais c'est bien beau
au maire c'est somme toute assez
théorique bien j'ai voulu illustrer avec
un exemple concret cet exemple qu'est ce
que c'est depuis quelques années on a
mis dans la même pièce à un certain
endroit de la planète des médecins des
psychologues des physiciens
les ingénieurs et des biologistes pour
qu'ensemble ils puissent développer une
nouvelle science c'est une science qui a
la particularité donc de mêlée toutes
ces disciplines et ses modes de
fonctionnement différent d'une science
qui va révolutionner notre notre société
l'étude de nos comportements
c'est une science qui va révolutionner
les neurosciences durant les prochaines
décennies la science qui a été développé
par cette équipe multidisciplinaire
c'est l'optogénétique
alors l'optogénétique qu'est ce que
c'est vous souvenez tout à l'heure le
petit talent que je vous ai montré
qu'ils étaient sains algues
unicellulaires qui crée de la lumière
dans le fond des océans et bien l'image
n'était pas choisie au hasard vous
verrez que dans cette présentation il ya
aucune image qui va être choisi au
hasard
eh bien on a étudié des biologistes et
des médecins ont étudié l'adn de cette
petite algue et ils ont isolé le gène
qui a pour rôle de créer cette molécule
qui quand on envoie un tout petit peu de
lumière attendant c'est bien à créer de
la fluorescence se gênent ils l'ont
extrait de l'ald et ils ont injecté dans
un virus toujours ses médecins
et ces biologistes ils ont injecté ce
virus dont le cerveau d'une souris alors
comme tous les virus qu'est ce qui va
faire vous avez un rhume le virus y
rentrer dans vos cellules détourne
véritablement la capacité de créer des
protéines et des molécules pour lui-même
et bien elle a ce virus là il va
affecter tous les neurones et les
cellules du cerveau de la souris et il
va donner la capacité à ses neurones de
créer cette molécule fluorescente
jusque là ça va ensuite c'est à ce
moment ci de rentrer en jeu
les ingénieurs et les physiciens ils ont
créé un système où on place une fibre
dans la tête de la souris et où on va
envoyer un peu de lumière qui aura comme
particularité qu'elle va permettre
d'allumer totalement les différents
neurones qui auront été infectées par la
protéine autrement dit cette nouvelle
science va avoir une particularité c'est
qu'elle va permettre de mieux localiser
dans certaines circonstances les
différents endroits du cerveau qui sont
en action et surtout
quand par exemple on à de l'anxiété
comment ça se fait que c'est un groupe
de neurones qui communique avec l'autre
autrement dit cette nouvelle science va
permettre de cartographier et bien le
cerveau et les liens les interconnexions
chaque partie du cerveau avec d'autres
partis dans certains cas de figure par
exemple ça va nous permettre de
comprendre pourquoi en ce moment il y a
quatre personnes qui regardent leurs
programmes et qui sont déconnectés
pourquoi lorsque je viens de dire ça
trois de ces quatre personnes viennent
de relever la tête de raccrocher à ma
présentation
ces nouvelles connaissances issues
d'études scientifiques vont permettre
également autre chose ça va permettre de
comprendre comme on l'a vu au tout
premier exposé l'anxiété permettent de
comprendre qu'est-ce qui se passe
physiquement dans un cerveau lorsque
vous êtes anxieux
alors ça va permettre de comprendre
aussi pourquoi dans cette salle il y as
je pense deux personnes qui en ce moment
sont assez anxieuse de personnes qui ont
probablement quelque chose d'un petit
problème ou quelque chose qu'il faut
régler qu'il faut résoudre ça va
permettre de comprendre aussi pourquoi
moi en tant que personne en face de vous
j'ai pu comprendre ça en analysant vos
micro expressions faciales
alors ça peut vous rassurer je ne vais
pas vous dire maintenant que j'ai vu
qu'il ya deux personnes qui vont
développer un cancer
rassurez vous ça n'est quand même pas
aussi balèze que ça voilà ça va
permettre aussi de comprendre tout un
ensemble de choses tout à fait
exceptionnelle mais sur le plan physique
ça permet de comprendre ces trois
individus alors ces trois individus les
est peut-être déjà vu
le premier c'est matthew savic c'est un
jeune américain de 23 ans alors battu
ses vaches
il est connu parce que c'est un
compositeur un joueur de piano
extraordinaire
qui connaît donc il a sorti plusieurs cd
il connaît toutes les symphonies de
beethoven etc
sauf qu'en fait la différence avec les
autres c'est qu'il a pris tout ça en une
nuit
comment on ne le sait pas encore c'est
l'exemple de reading gargam qui en fait
est un prodige mathématiques
vous allez dire à rüdiger rehlinger 23
exposants 57 + 5 102 exposants 23 lui
faudra environ trois à quatre secondes
pour vous donner la réponse exacte
ça permet également on va peut-être
comprendre comment ça se fait kim peek
est quelqu'un qui a lu 12 livres à la
différence qu'en fait il les a mémorisé
vous pouvez demander à kim peek fin où
malheureusement plus de ce monde mais
vous pouviez lui demander page 27 du
livre art de la guerre de sun tzu et kim
peek allez vous expliquer mot par mot
l'ensemble ce qui avait décrit à cette
page la c3 personnel sont atteints de ce
qu'on appelle un syndrome savant alors
il ya une composante autistique
mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que ses
capacités extraordinaires
vous les avez tous à portée de main tout
le monde a ses capacités à portée de
main
seul problème c'est qu'on ne sait pas
comment les atteindre à l'heure actuelle
il y a des cas qui ont été décrits dans
le monde où ils ont développé un
syndrome savant après avoir eu un avc ou
après avoir eu un traumatisme crânien ça
peut arriver à n'importe qui alors
imaginez vous un je ne parlerai pas ici
de prochaine étape de l'évolution de
l'espèce humaine
mais le fait d'en parler va peut-être
vous faire réfléchir par rapport à ce
que je viens de dire
imaginez-vous on arrive à comprendre
comment accéder à de telles capacités et
comment utiliser de telles capacités
dans notre vie de tous les jours c'est
probablement des équipes
multidisciplinaires qui arriveront
le second concept vous l'avez vu on a
démarré l'optogénétique depuis
l'existence d'une petite algue
unicellulaire qu est une algue verte
rien de plus banal véritablement eh bien
on a pu véritablement développé tout un
ensemble de concepts et de connaissances
sur le fonctionnement de vos cerveaux à
partir de la nature quand l'être humain
est apparue sur terre il ya des
millénaires
il n'était pas au courant n'était pas au
courant que la nature avait mis entre
ses mains tout un ensemble de choses
comme ça qui permettrait de répondre à
tout un ensemble de questions d'ailleurs
ceux-ci ceci étant au passage et je
ferai une petite aparté tout à la fin
pour les étudiants je joue avec votre
cerveau 1 depuis tout à l'heure nous
aurons des probablement pas compte mais
j'aime permet d'utiliser des accents
toniques sur certains mots des mots
importants
je me permet également de laisser des
pauses d'environ 2 secondes avant et
après vous avoir livré des informations
importantes parce que ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que si je commence à parler
donc avec un ton monocorde et monotone
sans réellement mettre de pause avant
les informations et après les
informations importantes et bien je suis
certain que vous auriez beaucoup plus de
mal intégré ce que je viens de dire vous
voyez vous avez un exercice positif plus
important plus difficiles à faire et
donc le second concept c'est
l'intégration davantage de ce que la
nature a mis à notre portée pour
développer la recherche vous souvenez
des quatre des quatre espèces que je
vous ai montré tout à l'heure eh bien
ces quatre espèces parmi plusieurs
millions d'espèces qui rien qu'à elles
seules peuvent également nous aider à
améliorer notre condition par exemple
ses bras ses bras fish qui est un
poisson pour retrouve dans nos aquariums
très fréquents eh bien il a la
particularité de savoir région
ray sa rétine il a la particularité de
savoir réparer son coeur après un
dommage comme par exemple si vous voulez
pour faire une comparaison avec l'être
humain un infarctus
il a la capacité également de régénérer
son cerveau et certaines régions
endommagé ce qui serait tout à fait
exceptionnel à développer chez nous
notamment dans la maladie de parkinson
alors cette algue unicellulaire je ne
vais pas revenir dessus j'en ai déjà
parlé
ce petit oiseau qu'on comtois dans les
milieux ruraux d'indonésie et des usa eh
bien il a la particularité que la nature
l'a doté d'un champ qui est très vite
altérée quand il ya un problème de
parkinson et donc on est en train grâce
à cet oiseau de comprendre ce qui se
passe sur le plan de la voix et du
discours chez les patients parkinsoniens
7 jaunes qui pour trou d'un reporter et
bien c'est le jean qui elle renferme une
molécule qui a comme capacité d'inhiber
est donc surtout de d'attaqué et de
réduire la prolifération des cancers du
cerveau
chacune des cellules chacune des
cellules qui composent ces espèces sur
terre a la particularité de nous livrer
d'avoir cette capacité de nous expliquer
des informations tout à fait
exceptionnelle pour améliorer notre
condition alors peut-être que les
sciences en médecine de demain vont
davantage être multidisciplinaire ça
c'est une popote qui appartient aux
médecins aux chercheurs etc
donc ça on le gérera mais le second
concept dont on a besoin pour changer le
monde et changer la recherche c'est le
respect et l'intégration de la nature
c'est quelque chose où chacun d'entre
vous peut avoir un rôle véritablement à
jouer au quotidien parce qu'il faut pas
se voiler la face si vous voulez donner
un avenir et un futur correct à vos
enfants
cet avenir passera par un respect de
notre environnement
respect de la nature et ce respect cet
acte au quotidien vont permettre à des
chercheurs comme nous de ne pas faire
évoluer la science mais de véritablement
révolutionné la science
je vous remercie